joe biden is under pressure gun violence
is ticking up so is violent crime the
white house knows it has to be seen to
be trying to get a grip of the problem
that's why i put together a
comprehensive strategy to supercharge
what works
one of the main areas of focus so called
ghost guns they can be built from a kit
you don't need a background check and
they have no serial numbers this is the
gun
it's not hard
to put together that makes them
unregulated and virtually untraceable
that can't stand says the president
let me ask you is it extreme to protect
police officers extreme to protect our
children
extreme to keep guns out of the hands of
people who couldn't even pass a
background check
look the idea that
someone on a terrorist list
could purchase one of these guns
is extreme it didn't extreme just basic
common sense
the white house also announced the new
head of the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms
steve dettelbach will be charged with
enforcing the crackdown if he's
confirmed to the position by the senate
what we need is a is a confirmed
director at etf we've only had one of
those um and it's really a detriment to
the agency's enforcement abilities i
mean this is just one example with with
this ghost gun rule going through that
we really need atf to be strong in the
enforcement side because if they don't
it's really just a rule on paper the
crackdown on ghost guns has been brewing
for months and it's an acceptance that
the rise in violence is a political
liability for the democrats but
it's almost certainly going to be
opposed by those who see it as an attack
on the second amendment of the
constitution the right to bear arms and
therefore it's almost certainly going to
end up in the courts
alan fisher al-jazeera at the white
house